well eric swalwell wants to launch an
investigation against axios because
they're the ones that broke the story
about his little uh what would you say
honey pot
um yes his uh his infiltration that
occurred between him
and uh this lady that infiltrated many
elements of
government in more ways than lady friend
yes it's a special lady friend did you
hear about the story about the
the spy i don't think you know what the
circus is really losing i stick much
more with like topics and
issues yeah well it is fascinating to
see china's influence especially over
our political system and especially with
how they've been
able to get all of our secrets and also
manipulate
uh you know the politicians like joe
biden very easily check out check out
the story
eric swalwell refuses to admit
wrongdoing over top secret friendship
with chinese spy fang fang
and demands probe into who leaked the
story
as he refuses to say if he slept with
her and she's still facebook friends
with his dad and brother
so a chinese honey trap spy who had been
organizing a fundraiser for this guy
and the fact that he would call for the
the journalists to get investigated
isn't it a matter of national security
this is the man who is a part of the
house intelligence committee
he has unrestricted access to classified
information
and this spy was with him before the
start of his major political career she
helped him fundraise
she helped him get support in the asian
community and many people say eric
swalwell
wouldn't be in power if it wasn't for
this spy
this spy should resign yes immediately
resign i mean there's there's no even
talking about this but when you look at
eric swalwell when you look at his major
points he's
he was a bastion a favorite of the
mainstream media to go up against
trump and many times he regurgitated a
lot of
beijing pro-communist government talking
points that
you saw him say and you saw the chinese
government say at the same time whether
it was
keeping the borders open to china during
the coronavirus scandal
whether it was going against trump
because of alleged russian collusion
whether it was even going against north
korea all the talking points by eric
swalwall on the mainstream media
almost perfect carbon copies of chinese
communist talking points
which does make you think especially
since now we're finding out that chinese
spy
helped him to get into power and and
it's not just him i mean dianne
feinstein had a uh do you know about
that one she had
she had a chinese spy working no it
doesn't surprise me and again i she is
one of those people that i i don't claim
we don't we don't claim her well that's
why i think
uh as i mentioned before like the real
fight is it's almost
you know i i everyone always says the
real fight is this group versus that
group but i think it's liberty versus
authority
because if you're in favor of freedoms
and liberty you're going to pose
censorship we're going to get along
you're going to
oppose the corporatist structure and the
crony government structures
by definition authority would be a form
of corporatism because you're bowing to
people who are paying your paycheck and
to your point about
saying that you're on the left luke's on
the left tim's on the left because they
support the idea of like restricting the
corporate powers yeah
i think that's very much a right-wing
idea because if you really care about a
free market
you really care about corporate america
like
backing off right you're not you would
be you would be
lack of government interference you
would be small government you would be
but
i think we've safely seen that both
sides are no longer what they're
supposed to be yeah
it's very blurred i mean it's not left
or right
it's if you're paying attention or if
you're not paying attention yeah it's if
you're with the corporate globalist
establishment or
if you're with the individual if you're
for freedom if you're liberty if you're
for the one
individual to be able to live their
lives freely without anyone
putting their thumb over them that's
amazing do you like the constitution
i love the constitution you see that's
that's the big thing the the the
authorities the establishment the
corporate
actually wonderful i know it's
fascinating right
i know i love it when p i love when
people start saying something like well
i've read it so i'm quite familiar but
no i take that very seriously i wouldn't
swear over a bible but i'd swear over
the constitution they
oh yeah absolutely me too they they have
uh uh
i say they but like these big corporate
interests these authoritarian
these uh despotic government officials
have tried so
hard to crush the working class and the
constitution has been our saving grace
right now with the lockdowns with what's
happening yeah
first thing i want to say just to keep
in kind of line we're talking about the
the chinese spies and stuff
why isn't china under a lockdown what's
going on how come we're seeing these big
resurgences in europe and the us but
nothing in china
i don't know i find it all very look
i've had a lot of
questions about this whole thing from
the beginning like i am not a cove
denier i am a complete denier of our
ability to contain it and control it
so i to me it's i am
i'm also a darwinist let me be i mean
it's it's sad i'm not denying that it's
happening and i'm doing everything i can
to be wrong it doesn't sound very
leftist
i'm doing no but i also told you when it
comes to things like civil liberties i'm
very libertarian
um i i also believe that there's a lot
of personal
accountability so i'm going to do
everything i can to be respectful of
other people and wear my mask and not
you know
just so that other people i don't want
to be get someone else sick like i don't
want to do that
but i generally don't believe in um
squishing our civil liberties you know
i thought of something really funny
earlier like a good idea for a skit
where it's a guy who's wearing a mask
but no shirt and he goes into a store
and they're like you got to get out of
here and he's like what you can't make
me wear a shirt you're all under you're
being controlled man
it's like you know that my response is
i'm not i
i you know i don't care about masks it's
like they put up a sign saying no shirt
no she was no service and they added
masks to it and i'm kind of like i roll
my eyes i mean it kind of sucks and i
don't like wearing it but you know what
that that's not a sword i'm willing to
die on yeah
i don't it doesn't it doesn't matter so
i i forgot exactly
where i was going with everything but i
was going to say that
the lockdown has been this massive
transfer of wealth in more ways than
just shutting down small businesses and
keeping open
big corporations the vaccine itself is a
massive transfer of wealth
guaranteed contracts to big
pharmaceutical companies and then they
tell them straight up get the
vaccine as fast as possible there's no
liability for you they're exempt
and then you'll get a guaranteed two
billion dollar sale so
that's our taxes you won't no you want
to know why i won't
because they were warned they just uk
just warned people not to take it if you
have allergies
so you actually yeah it's been it's been
it's been advised against that and in
russia they're telling people if you do
take the vaccine you can't drink for two
months oh russia is
that's interesting and so why aren't we
hearing that about that here i mean not
that we have
well there's a lot of different side
effects and when you look at the list of
possible side effects that you could get
from this
vaccine there are a little bit uh
worrisome to say
well let's let's make sure we're in line
with the acceptable news guard
the npr reports uk regulators tell
people with severe allergies not to get
the vaccine
i don't think uh i'm actually concerned
they said severe allergies because
in the trials it was reported in this
warning
about one in uh 0.6
of people had an anaphylactic reaction
okay so do you guys know what that is
yeah
your face and eyes swell up your throat
closes you die and when they were giving
the first run through
the first release to healthcare workers
in the uk two of the nurses had an
anaphylactic reaction
and fortunately they were in a hospital
with epipens nearby epinephrine
so you've you've got minutes yeah i mean
you're gonna you're gonna asphyxiate
so they they jab you with the epipen
it's it's like an adrenaline uh
analog and then you come back out of it
very pulp fiction
yes very poor fiction they issued uh uh
they issued a warning saying that the
vaccine can only be administered in
places that have
resuscitation capacity that's not a
that's not a selling point
no no no no no the first thing i'll say
is
take your advice from your doctor this
is this this is you know what's really
funny i tweeted this out
very bland i said uh you know 0.685
of people had an anaphylactic reaction
uk doctors are advising people with
allergies to avoid the vaccine
and then i had a bunch of people calling
me an anti-vaxxer you're an anti-vaxxer
i'm like
you're an antivirus i'm i'm
pro-government in this position right
the government has said this why are you
nuts
yeah you run the risk of it's crazy you
could get banned for saying this stuff
and i'm reading npr
they're warning us about this biden just
tweeted out that he wants 100 million
vaccines yeah well that's the one thing
during the presidential debates that
biden and trump were all on page of they
argued about everything except for the
vaccine and how
how much we need it how quickly we need
to get it out there to everyone
and when you look at the vaccine we have
to understand which one we're talking
about because there's many different
ones out there there's many different
big pharma companies out there there's
pfizer that's the one specifically
this is the vaccine the russian one is a
completely different
vaccine that's out there but we have to
understand a lot of these companies are
rushing to be the first
to market that's a very important
economic term for companies that want to
make a lot of money
and when you have that and you have no
liability no
recourse to get punished if you do
something very wrong what could go wrong
exactly especially from big pharma that
absolutely
i mean we could you know you could say
good things and positive things about
them but
they do have a bad record sometimes when
we
no i'm not saying anything positive well
it depends
there's some people that say that you
know big farmers saved their lives
but with our tax dollars well a lot of
the medicine especially
now that's being used to treat covet 19
patients
was subsidized by the taxpayer and now
it's being sold at the highest bidder
for thousands of dollars at the
hospitals which is absolutely ridiculous
that's how all of it happened meanwhile
when there's doctors there was there was
a pathologist
on on youtube his name's chris martinson
he just released a video talking about
alternative solutions that there's
scientific studies behind
that might actually work that have been
promising his video gets censored his
video gets taken down it was fully
deleted on youtube yeah well look look
at the
one of the craziest things was uh
breitbart getting censored on facebook
and you know i made the joke about
newsguard because uh are you familiar
with newsguard i reference them quite a
bit they're a they're a micros they're
microsoft funded right
i have no idea it's this this they they
give a rating to news outlets says like
green checkmark
exclamation point as a safeguard and
check out my bias i
you know the sources i use are always
news guard certified even though i'm
critical of newsguard in many ways i
think it's it's fair to be like okay
it's a baseline
yeah you know i could be biased and just
read breitbart but what happened was
breitbart was actually certified and
approved until they
filmed a press conference from a pilot
from it was a
republican congressman and a bunch of
doctors that's all they did they filmed
it
they live streamed it on their facebook
page it got deleted
and then they got accused of publishing
fake news
because they filmed the press conference
yeah imagine if imagine if you're doing
a press conference with joe biden
and joe biden said trinidad a shabbat a
pressure
they're going to come after my news
organization because joe biden said
something
right that's crazy that's that's that's
the level of censorship we're at thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you